happy prayer day you liberal heathens
May 7th is the official National Day of
Prayer and this is a big year because
it's the first time a modern president
has declared the United States to not be
a Christian nation yeah he said that
well hopefully all you Christian Obama
voters are starting to get the picture
but you know who's got to be happy about
it are the liberal folks at the ACLU
well I for one put it refreshing of a
cerebral candidate finally take office
like run tired of us red state hooligans
clinging to their guns and religion
dearest dearest where's my glove you
know I can't smoke my mirror without my
glove listen whether you like it or not
this country was founded on
judeo-christian principles well what
about the separation of church and state
you know I hear those words used all the
time here's a copy of the Constitution
find them huh well well though I believe
it's implied yes no where are the words
separation of church and state found in
this document they were written in a
private letter from Thomas Jefferson to
the Danbury Baptists addressing a
concern regarding a specific state
enforced denomination people like to
take those words and apply them to the
First Amendment which was designed to
keep the government out of church and
not faith-based principles out of
government every year of the Church of
England it was an institutionalized
religion and corrupt church because the
government had their hand in it we wrote
the First Amendment because we did not
want that happening in the United States
well young boy Thomas Jefferson was an
atheist no he wasn't well maybe not in a
classical sense but he was a deist at
most certainly he wasn't a Christian no
in his day was considered a deist
because he wasn't a devout practicing
Christian but his belief in a higher
power was that of the judeo-christian
God and not some abstract guiding force
to the universe by today's standards
Napolitano would consider him a
Christian right-wing extremist the
United States laws are based on biblical
laws include
the first amendment allowing us to
worship freely the fact that this was
founded as a true Christian nation is
what makes it the best place on earth
for Jews atheists and Muslims alike and
all of this is why people like the ACLU
are not anti religion they're
anti-christian yes
yes true you're telling me they won't
watch you while you're burka on your
driver's license oh well that's a ranger
sir come quickly
some children they're saying the Pledge
of Allegiance wha-oh
don't even get the ACLU started on the
horror that is the Pledge of Allegiance
stop narration they took the children
they made them say please please
human the whole nation under God version
the children
screaming screaming
may God have mercy on us all oh that
that offends me huh oh yes I suppose
you're right how insensitive me oh well
may we all be spare no you can't think
that either wrong yes
I guess that implies that there is
actually a greater power that could
spare us and still quite offensively out
well let's just say it's a bad situation
all around and call it a day to everyone
out there who does believe in God go out
and practice your inalienable rights by
praying freely god bless you and God
bless america
our Father who art in heaven hallowed on
the kingdom
why can't you shut up I'm going to show
you for every penny of God